diplomatic efforts are intensifying on
both sides of the atlantic to resolve
the ukraine crisis in washington u.s
president joe biden held talks with
german chancellor olaf schultz biden
stressed that germany is a reliable
partner and that they will work together
to try and find a diplomatic solution
meanwhile french president emmanuel
macron traveled to moscow for talks with
russian president vladimir putin macron
said the next few days would be decisive
in efforts to avoid conflict putin said
he was willing to compromise
an urgent diplomatic push
world leaders met in the russian
and u.s capitals in an effort to diffuse
tension over ukraine
in his first visit to washington as
german chancellor olaf schultz sat down
with u.s president joe biden to pursue
what they called a diplomatic resolution
to the crisis
i have been very very straightforward
and blunt with
president putin both on the phone and in
person
we will impose the most severe sanctions
that have ever been imposed economic
sanctions i think he has to realize that
it would be a
gigantic mistake for him to move
on ukraine the impact on europe and the
rest of the world would be devastating
one of the biggest targets for sanctions
is the nordstream 2 pipeline project to
bring gas from russia to germany
biden said in clear terms he would shut
it down if russia invades
but schultz made no such guarantee
vowing only a unified response
we will be united we will act together
and we will take all the necessary steps
and all the necessary steps will be done
by all of us together will you commit
today to turning off and pulling the
plug on nordstrom too you didn't mention
it you haven't mentioned it as i already
said we are acting together we are
absolutely united and we will not taking
different steps we will do the same
steps and they will be very very hard to
russia and they should understand
with at least 100 000 russian troops
massed along ukraine's border berlin has
faced international criticism for its
cautious response
unlike some of its nato allies germany
has ruled out sending weapons to ukraine
meanwhile in moscow french president
emmanuel macron focused on de-escalation
russia's vladimir putin reiterated his
demands for nato to stay out of the
region but said he was willing to
compromise
a number of macron's ideas and proposals
which are probably too early to speak
about
i consider quite possible to use in
forming the basis of our further joint
steps
as far as we are concerned we will do
everything to find compromises that suit
everyone
will hold talks in kiev on tuesday
before heading to berlin
a long week of diplomacy for european
leaders hoping to avoid conflict
well for more let's speak to gerhard
mangat he's a professor of international
relations at the university of innsbruck
and an expert on russian and u.s foreign
policy thanks for joining us professor a
flurry of diplomacy is underway focusing
on russia and ukraine let's start with
that meeting between the german and u.s
leaders in washington are you convinced
by the show of unity between schultz and
biden
well definitely it was important for mr
schultz to show that germany is a
reliable ally and that's what he said we
are absolutely united but it was uh
really noticeable that after biden
confirmed that nordstrom 2 would not go
ahead after a russian incursion in
ukraine
schultz did not want to state that
explicitly as well so we still have
doubts whether in the case of a russian
incursion in ukraine the german
government will really be ready uh to
stop nordstrom 2. on the other side
biden has made clear even if the
germans don't do it we have the means
available to stop it and we will stop it
okay the nordstrom 2 pipeline project
has been a thorn in the side of german
u.s relations for quite some time but
why do you think aside from that why do
you think the two leaders are being so
vague about the sanctions they would
impose if russia does invade ukraine
again
well it seems that there's some disunity
between the two sides maybe among
various other nato allies as well
if that would not be the case
they will clearly have stated what kind
of sanctions will be imposed in the case
of a russian incursion but they have not
done so we have had statements by
biden administration officials about
what type of sanctions they are
envisaging but it seems that
there's still some work to do to unite
at least the germans and the americans
on what to do after after such a
military invasion
let's move on to moscow uh french
president emmanuel macron met uh
president putin there yesterday putin
hinted at a possible compromise in the
ukraine crisis
any idea what he meant by that
well it was very noticeable that ahead
of the talks between putin and macron
macron stated that
a finlandization of ukraine
was on the table uh finlandization means
that ukraine would be absolutely free in
its domestic politics but would be
limited in its foreign policy options
this refers to the status of finland
during the cold war
which could preserve its independence in
democracy only by clearly stating that
it will remain neutral and non-aligned
in the conflict between the west and and
the soviet union so macron is actually
envisioning
that ukraine takes the same position and
i'm not very sure that he is on the same
page with the us and other nato allies
on this issue
president tamakon is due in kiev today
uh
what are your expectations there
well first of all macron will confirm
that the territorial integrity and
sovereignty of ukraine is undisputable
that that france is a is a partner of
ukraine on on this matter and that
france is doing everything it can to
diffuse the crisis and de-escalate
militarily however what's important is
what what is not going to be spoken
about afterwards namely the proposals
that macron has made in moscow to
vladimir putin
macron needs to find out what the
ukrainians think about it and if there
is any chance that ukraine might agree
to some sort of neutralization of the
country in the future professor manga
thank you very much for your insight sir
that was gerhard maggot professor of
international relations at the
university of innsbruck
well for more i'm joined by our
washington correspondent carolina chimoy
carolina
u.s visit coincided with the french
president's trip to moscow is there a
sense in washington that all this
diplomacy is making another russian
invasion of ukraine less likely
well it's more a hope than a sensory
it's definitely showing how much effort
the west is putting into this diplomatic
uh path to to solve uh and and to find a
solution um to this crisis in ukraine as
you mentioned the french president met
president putin in moscow today um or
yesterday and he is going today to meet
the president of poland mr duda and
chancellor schultz in berlin for three
three-day summit on the crisis in
ukraine and next week chancellor schultz
is going to meet ukraine's president mr
zelensky on monday and russia's
president vladimir putin on tuesday so
yes
the western world is talking about
sanctions but at the same time the
diplomatic negotiations and the efforts
are the current strategy and this is
showing that uh the west is talking with
one voice or at least this is the image
that they want to
give to to russia and that is also what
mr schultz and president biden made very
clear yesterday they are united towards
russia and the next days will definitely
be decisive on this
so a big diplomatic push the german and
u.s leaders uh keen to show unity at
their meeting but how united are they
really karolina in their approach the
u.s and germany in their approach to
russia and ukraine
this is a very good question because
you're right they're trying to show
unity and this was part of the strategy
yesterday but they did not share any
details on how united they are for
example talking about about sanctions
against russia um
what what would happen if russia would
invade invade ukraine how would the
sanctions really look like we don't have
details on that the gas pipeline for
example that would deliver liquid gas
from russia to germany also known as
north stream ii was one of the main
points here and while president baiden
made crystal clear that there will be no
north stream two if russia invades
ukraine chancellor schultz did not even
mention the name of the pipeline and
kept on talking about unity so um there
is a big
show trying to show unity but we don't
know further details on this and
apparently there are certain points
where they are not really united
now germany's reliability as an ally has
been questioned not least because of
berlin's refusal to supply ukraine with
weapons
has chancellor schultz done anything
during his visit to assure america's top
brass that germany can be counted on as
a defense partner
this aspect on a weapons supply to
ukraine is also a problematic one uh
between germany and the united states
schultz has reiterated that germany is
one of the biggest donors to ukraine
with 2 billion euros every year but he
has not mentioned any changes regarding
uh the weapons supply to russia and
still unity and our most important
allies these were the key words to
yesterday's press conference but no
further details on this problematic
issue siri
carolina thank you so much our
washington correspondent carolina chimoy
there
you